the candidates just finished what was
your top take away from the tournament
it went like i expected except for the
winner because for some reason because i
just don't know so well nepamyasi i
don't know him
so well and
i didn't really expect him to repeat i
believed that it was very difficult to
win two times in a row basically
jan rolled away with it
it was
impressive to watch he
took her off his chances and
prevailed prevailed deservedly ian
nepomnyashi kind of run off with the
tournament i was following
it at the beginning
but then he
just started to win game after game i
would say
it was kind of unexpected because he won
the previous candidates and
usually it's hard to to win it
twice in a row i chose my bet was
fabiano was going to win it
and the americans both played decently
but
it wasn't enough there's only one winner
in the canvas as we can see
yes there was a lot of
absolute ups and downs and
the tournament was very tough and i took
a lot of experience there
and yeah
it was a very good tournament for me
because all the players were experienced
and
i managed to get a lot of experience
there so but it was very interesting the
tournament i think
the players were playing
very aggressively not like in previous
years
everyone was trying to win with with
both pieces and there was a lot of
interesting openings and ideas
actually not many not many
berlins or some some other solid
openings so
i think
jan is in a very good shape so that his
winning is not that surprising but still
he has a very good chances
in the match
it was
it was great to see jan in in such a
good shape i think
it's not very common to to to have a
player dominate the field and in the
candidates like that
because usually it's uh it's some
tremendous fight and some some players
who are not doing very well in the first
half
they usually get back in the second half
and
they produce some upsets and it wasn't
the case like ian was really untouchable
personally i would have liked to see a
little bit more from ali raza furusha
since
i really like his playing style and i
think he has
or he might be
the next world champion
at some point at least but he didn't do
so well here but i'm sure he'll do
well when he gets another chance
young played a fantastic strong
tournament and he deserved to play again
against magnus in much
i wish him all the best in the match i
hope
he magnus will play much and we will say
good much it was a great experience and
i mean maybe i would say emotionally it
wasn't as
as much uh
as it was one year ago because you know
probably on you know in some way only
the first time counts but
yeah i'm i'm insanely proud of
of my team who did tremendous work to
help me yeah i'm really glad so
i managed to please my friends the
candidates sort of reaffirmed
my my own experience from nine years ago
that's really really tough i think in
order to
to win the the tournament you yeah a lot
of things have to
have to go right
or you have to get a little bit
lucky like i did
[Music]